is Kevin Hart funny what do you think
when people say that it's Kevin Hart
funny no I just got here by being stupid
well wait a minute hey what's going on
this is Kevin Hart I'm about to answer
some questions on the Internet it's
actually me okay
[Music]
Cora I never heard of them what's this
how did Kevin Hart and Dwayne The Rock
Johnson's Bromance begin well his career
was it was over he needed help so
naturally what did he do call the okay
heart
I came on board changed that man's life
by the way you're welcome
you're welcome because we know the truth
before me he had that stupid movie Tooth
Fairy we all knew what was happening
after that
then boom Central Intelligence
shoots to the moon when will Kevin Hart
retire okay now what
these people are just mean I don't know
I'm 43 so I hope I got a little bit of
time left
I definitely want to go while
well I'm On Top gotta find a new fund
like in the space of interviewing and
podcasts for my show Heart to Heart and
comedy gold mines this is something
that's Evergreen like I've actually
interviewed a lot of people I'm also
artist friendly I don't believe in the
space of sabotaging talent I Amplified
Talent so coming on any platform of mine
is about celebrating you and what you've
done in your world of success and I
don't do any prep
no prep
no pre-interviews no here's what we
talking about uh here's the marketing
promo I don't do none of that come
on my show we're just gonna talk what
did Kevin Hart say to Jeff Bezos when
they met what kind of boots are those
Jeff Bezos had on some goddamn boots
I've never seen Leather So Clean
got on the goddamn I might have been a
combo pack like Python and Cobra and
Gator all at the same time what do most
people not know about Kevin Hart that I
am a phenomenal spoons player
mm-hmm
give me two spoons I'll get down
Wikipedia oh heart's first stand-up
performance took place at the lab house
in his native Philadelphia under the
name of low Kev which did not go well
his career suffered a slow start and he
was booed off stage several times what
the is your problem Wikipedia
what's what's even having a piece of
chicken thrown at him you know I don't I
didn't get booed off stage that's
aggressive I did get hit with a piece of
chicken though that's factual but they
didn't boo me the chicken just landed
and I felt it was the best decision to
get off the stage after that buffalo
sauce got my eye it's pretty tough to
finish a joke when you got goddamn
habanero sauce in your eye so I left but
I didn't get booed
no boo Hart briefly attended the
Community College of Philadelphia before
dropping out and moving New York City he
then moved to Brockton Massachusetts and
found the workers ship I never lived in
Massachusetts and why would they go
Brockton like what
that's racist what just happened
what just happened nobody wants to
address the bigger issue here
Wikipedia hates black people I said it
there it is cats out the bag
salesman part that's actually factual I
was one of the best shoe salesman ever
ever to do it I can tell you whatever
you need subinate Pro Nate condensed Eva
polyurethane what kind of support do you
need high arch flat feet are you looking
for something that protects your shins a
little more you want forefoot protection
I know all that stuff I could work for
any shoe company still to date if I
chose to throw this world of success and
fame in the trash can and Chase a career
as a shoe salesman I could my favorite
shoe Nike did a running shoe called the
epics which are really good it's a dope
shoe just because it's condensed Eva in
that shoe so it's a softer bottom better
for impact and when you run depending on
how you go whether it's Heel To Toe or
toe to heel it provides a better
smoother Run for the long run see I
could have sold that look at y'all y'all
want to buy them now
you welcome right now you know who makes
really good running shoes hocus look
like goddamn River rafts on your feet
yeah
ain't the best looking shoe but they're
comfortable as hell all right these are
from Twitter I wonder how Kevin Hart
feels about him randomly being a meme
I thought it was stupid that's
my answer you know this meme thing just
really showed me how my face kind of
fits any mood or any narrative but I
just don't know what I did to deserve it
y'all can kiss my ass with that one I
don't understand it
did Kevin Hart really buy an eagle
goddamn right I did spent 15 million
dollars on that eagle Stanley bald eagle
in California Eagle season coming up you
know it's a little Bittersweet we almost
got the job done came up short you know
lost a bunch of money whatever I'm not
here to be sour or get into great detail
doesn't look like my kids are going to
school anytime soon based off of that
loss so we'll see how it pans out next
season
Kevin Hart is a good actor when he's
serious what the does that mean I
guess is that a compliment what is that
I would assume that uh she's talking
about fatherhood or the upside or true
story which is where I put my little my
serious side on display I enjoy it but I
like comedy more those are just little
nuggets that I wanted to give my fan
base just to see that I got that in my
bag
um
oh these are from Reddit oh how
would you rank all the Kevin Hart
stand-up specials that he's done over
the years uh number one number one
number one number one number one number
one number one seven I'm about to
release someone wow I'm at eight I
didn't know I thought I was at seven I'm
at eight my next one is called reality
check so it seems that they're still
going up hopefully I get the ten if I
don't get old and start forgetting jokes
Draymond Green was a 34 three-point
shooter before her facing Kevin Hart a
Three-Point Contest since then he's a 30
three-point shorter yeah because he
sucks
that's why I suck it Draymond listen I
could have went to the NBA okay comedy
chose me there I said it I had a choice
NBA stand up comedy I started playing
when I was two months as a baby I was
blessed with big calves so my jumping
ability out the womb was insane six
months I was grabbing the net it was
nothing like it so the doctors call me
little special boots because uh I had
the hard bottom shoes but I was able to
jump like no other baby could
is Kevin Hart funny what do you think
people say that it's Kevin Hart funny no
I just got here by being stupid
well wait a minute
all right YouTube here we go everyone
talks about Kevin and The Rock but I'm
Still Loving Kevin's original Duo Kevin
Hart and Anthony Anderson that is my guy
man me and Anthony had a lot of fun
doing those scary movies yeah we were
used after they stole the franchise from
the Wayne brothers yeah me and Anthony
worked together a lot man I'm joking
about that but there's a little bit of
that so they needed two other black guys
they picked me and Anthony uh next one
you think Kevin's family would ever do a
movie together no
no I don't want my family in a business
I think my daughter's going to be in the
business my son maybe my daughter
definitely my daughter loves development
creativity I see producing in our future
I see acting and a proof like she can do
kind of what she wants she's talented so
we'll see but the business is it's a lot
it's a lot to deal with so I don't want
my kids in it to another place to handle
it
deal with the highs and lows
Instagram all right how did this man
have Proverbs 24
817 businesses and movies and still
manage to do Tick Tock dances and I
don't know
I don't know I don't really understand
Tick Tock like that so I had to go find
some people that do my first videos on
Tick Tock was just I'm about to do a
tick tock
here comes a tick tock
all right y'all want to see me do a tick
tock
but now I can actually do a tick tock so
it's kind of cool who are your top five
favorite comedians of all time wow good
question
huh
Dave Chappelle Eddie Murphy
Chris Rock Martin Lawrence Richard Pryor
damn that's tough because I'm leaving
out I mean Bill Burr and Patrice O'Neal
Seinfeld George Carlin
Wanda Sykes how does he still find so
much new material to write jokes about
travel
engaging with people and
environments that I'm not normally
accustomed to having kids being involved
in your kids life growing up getting
older realizing the things you can't do
at the level that you once did
change within change comes great
opportunity
well
by the way it was actually me uh I
answered all your questions to the best
of my ability I hope you're happy and do
me a favor make sure you watch Die Hard
March 31st it's going down uh great
laughs great story a lot of fun all
right until next time